akram imran can only go on his land four
times a year
israel declared this area in burun
village north of the occupied west bank
a closed military zone in 2016.
it's near an illegal israeli settlement
and he needs an israeli permit to enter
these are unripe olives so they don't
generate much oil but i'm forced to pick
them now which means i will lose this
season
he hired workers to help him pick as
many olives as possible in the short
time he's given
his absence from the land prevents him
from tending his crop
but he says what's worse is that he sees
settlers attacking his trees and can't
stop them
even when amran saw his land being
burned two months ago he couldn't access
it when he was finally allowed to visit
his plantation earlier this month he
says more than half of his trees were
damaged
while israeli authorities cite security
concerns for not allowing farmers in
imran says the goal is to push
palestinians out
they want to take it from us our
neighbors who were here left their lands
after continuous settler attacks
now they took it over and planted grapes
instead of olives just before his permit
ended for the day emran sent us this
video of subtler groups attempting to
attack him and his workers human rights
organizations have documented a dramatic
increase in violent attacks by settlers
this year
activist abdullah abraham says new
generations of settlers are more violent
so they formed local committees to
protect farmers
most of the time the israeli army
protects the settlers even when they're
attacking palestinians that's why we
want farmers to be in groups and not
alone
palestinian officials say there's an
imbalance of power and have called on
other states to put settlers on their
list of so-called terror groups
this campaign aims to provide protection
to the palestinian people from settlers
terror we want states to change their
domestic law so settlers will be held
accountable
in the meantime
imran hopes his trees will be safe until
he's allowed to go back to his land
nida ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied
west bank